hello hello well we are live one minute
to spare welcome welcome to the uh
Copenhagen developer conference
SAA um I hope we're all going to feel
nice and warm by the end of the session
because I know I
am um so I'm here to talk to you about
intentional code and really what this is
is a response so that feeling you get
when you try and use a system and you
try and fix a system and everything just
kind of sucks and everyone's
kind of been there there's just this
horrible feeling where you you try to
maintain a piece of software and you
open it up and you're peeling away
layers upon layers of kind of needless
abstraction that seems to give you
nothing just to find that one file with
the four lines in the middle that
actually does the work and we all have
systems like this we all own them and
like it's it's pretty tedious and it
scares me so this is hopefully a bit of
an antidote a bit of a salve to that
horrible visceral pain so we're all
going to feel it
together so my name is David and I spend
a lot of time thinking about software
design it's kind of my toxic character
trait um so I'm the head of architecture
for a company called New Day based out
of London um and I'm really here to talk
to you about why design itself is
important and why every single thing
matters um that you know the truth is
I'm a programmer and you're going to
primy my keyboard out my cold dead hands
um regardless of the job title you stick
on top of it so it doesn't matter what
kind of role that you hold in your
technical organization this is this is
really for you with that said there's
not a lot of code in this talk because
what I really want to think about here
is software design that's what I want us
to be
considering now I did a bit of a a small
viral tweet sorry a viral XZ you know
that that same joke at the end of uh
last year that seem to resonate with a
lot of people so I was trying to fix
this pretty architecturally awful code
base and as soon as I opened up my IDE
my heckles were raised by this god-
awful organizational pattern that you'll
see here so I did what I always do when
I see something I hate I opened Twitter
and rage tweeted into the void to make
sure that everyone felt as bad as I did
about the thing and I remember just
sitting there thinking this is like a
damning indictment on the state of
software design in
2023 so Twitter obviously agreed at the
time but mostly the thing that really
jumped out me when I was looking at this
code base was really how shitty and
thoughtless it all was it was all really
really thoughtless this organizational
pattern you know organiz organizing code
by architectural feature is like way up
there on the lists of horrible like hate
crimes you can do to your software um
it's something that has no real meaning
and it it buries everything and you sit
there and you think why would someone do
this there isn't an answer that's the
problem there is no why um so hopefully
throughout the session we're going to
try and answer the question why is
everything like
this now as the joke goes organizing
your code by architectural feature is
exactly this picture it's taking a
classic car collection and splitting it
up into tires wind screens Bonnets and
engines and saying come and enjoy
this now so much of talk about design
when we think about software and and the
form of code always ends up getting
dragged back to the work done in the 90s
mostly about design patterns now this
isn't a talk about design patterns but I
want to pay them a little bit of lip
service and due respect because you know
it might perhaps be easy to misinterpret
what I'm about to say as some horrendous
tyde against design patterns and
whenever you say design patterns are bad
everyone gets very very angry and the
pitchforks come out um this isn't a cry
against standards it's not a cry against
patterns but first we have to understand
what design patterns really were because
I think what people call them today are
really not what they were intended to be
now design patterns themselves
originated in the works of Christopher
Alexander who was like an actual real
life building architects of buildings
that weren't allowed to fall down um who
wrote this beautifully titled book
called notes on the synthesis of form
which is also the name of my like
Progressive death metal album I think um
and it was consumed by cons computer
science researchers throughout the 70s
and ' 80s including specifically people
like Kent Beck and Ward Cunningham who
around the 80s started writing around
about pattern languages in software
design now you end up with with things
like the gang of four book that came out
in 1994 and you know it's probably the
foundational text that talks about
design patterns and software and what it
did is it attempted to lay out a series
of structural creational and behavioral
patterns as they were observed in common
software of the era and that's really
important like they were looking around
themselves identifying things that they
were seeing there were a bunch of other
books that followed things like Kent
Beck writing Small Talk best practices
and the the the classic Martin Fowler
patterns of Enterprise architecture that
everyone read in the year 2000 or then
about but ultimately the intention of
all these books was exactly one thing
and it was to provide concrete guidance
and description of common solutions to
common problems they weren't saying
here's how you should build things they
were saying here's how we have seen
people build things and what they really
are like design patterns are an aspect
of language what they they're trying to
do is give model answers to model
questions and provide names of things
that you see so you can talk about them
and that's like super super valuable
work right like if you don't have a name
for things you can't describe it you
can't communicate about it and so much
of what we do in software is lost when
we really end up with lots and lots of
names for the same things so you know
this isn't a talk about design patterns
but all that work was really good
work categories of problems that are the
same same this talk is about everything
that isn't the
same now I suppose I just kind of lament
the fact that most talk of design in
software is kind of grouped up into this
talk of design patterns because they're
really the least interesting part all
the stuff that everyone does all the
time um if design patterns are about the
parts of the systems that are familiar
and with the exceptions that you know we
push programming languages to innovate
over time hopefully the the theory goes
that our programming languages should
make some of these design patterns from
the foundational Works basically
obsolete at this point right it feels
like we kind of forgot to really talk
about everything that wasn't predictable
or common and you know really design
patterns are kind of bug fixes for gaps
in your programming languages if you
have to do the same thing over and over
again and that's where real design
starts when the talk of patterns end and
you're just left with trying to work out
what to do with the rest of everything
that is your actual
software now on the other end of the
spectrum
and we have kind of large scale
architectural discussions and
conversations about design and you you
end up just seeing The Usual Suspects of
stuff like n tier hexagonal architecture
12 Factor apps now these all try and
offer prescriptive rules around how you
should arrange the form of an
application and but I think kind of
software design has more than just those
two axes of functional patterns and
large scale architecture and I think all
the most interesting parts of software
design are the incidental moments of
about the way the programmers interact
with their code it's the every other
line it's the daytoday it exists in the
Gap so here's the funny story back in
the depths of time I was an art student
um like painting and stuff um but more
importantly I also studied literature
and English language and design and Fine
Art and painting in the 90s in high
school and I spe spe specialized we're
going to go with that in literature and
politics I but I always wanted to be a
programmer and that's because computers
were like magic and they were exciting
and they were making things right but
for the first half of my career and when
I was learning for that kind of first 10
years in high school I just really
struggled to reconcile this aesthetic
sensibility of design with the works
around design as it was kind of rendered
into programming and all those books
about design pens they just seem to have
a completely different aesthetic
Viewpoint than I was used to
um and I then went on and did a computer
science degree after coming from this
pure arts background uh which I didn't
particularly enjoy but during the first
year of compai I came across Donald nth
like every first year computer science
student and he wrote the famous series
of books that are still being written in
the art computer programming um but he
also wrote about this concept that he
described as literate programming which
was a book he published way back in
1984 um literally the year I was born so
no new ideas in computer
software now new had tried to get
traction around in the space around the
idea that software should be written by
combining a programming language and a
documentation language and they both
were combined and run side by side to
produce the the source code he was
really obsessed with this idea that um
your your software should be read like a
book and you know the the funny thing is
like having this kind of artsy approach
to it is very consistent with someone
like Donald n who spent 10 years writing
texts so he could write a book he's like
he must be the king of yak shaving at
that point um and you know if you think
about it the languages that nth was
talking about the time in the 70s really
were a lot more primordial we'll go with
that they were they were a lot simpler
they were a lot more structured a lot
more rigid and less expressive than the
languages we have today and actually
modern programming languages are in
order of magnitude closer to what he was
dreaming of when he thought about
literate programming how about things
that were legible and could be read by
humans rather than just
machines um he was kind of right and he
was Vindicated by subsequent 30 years of
development into programming languages
that dragged programming languages into
a more expressive form and that core
idea really resonated with me the the
the thing where he was like oh well it's
really it should be like the index page
of a book and you flip through the pages
I was like you know what yeah software
it really is the same as literature it
really really is
and this was a little bit of a
revelation to kind of baby programmer me
because it totally changed the way that
I started writing code because I started
specifically optimizing for that thing
because I realized that software only
became good literature if you treated it
like good literature and try to arrange
it in those organizational
patterns so over the years I've come to
this real precise definition of what I
really think software is um software is
a constraint form of communication
between programmer and programmer that
describes Concepts and problems but also
happens to be executable by
machines and I've thought about this a
lot and I think I believe it it's it's
probably a heel I would die on and you
know the more you think about it the
more it starts making sense you spend so
much more of your day reading code than
you do writing it your code exists in a
context it has subtext it has authorial
intent your code has flow it has form it
has Rhythm it has tone just like any
other writing sometimes the authorial
intent is not what gets rendered into
the the screen and that's kind of where
bugs come from right like the analogy
works but most importantly your code has
reason it has a reason for existing it
has
intent now here's the bit where everyone
gets to be mad at me because I tell them
to burn books and burning books is
heresy um burn burn your copies of clean
code it's the book that everyone always
cites as the foundational work on
software design and it's aged so poorly
um it means we don't have to deal with
problematic family members um it's an
extremely dogmatic book and it's
presence in the industry honestly has
kind of muted so much conversation
around design to things to design to to
conversations about naming variables
it's muted conversations around
architectural style in the same way that
people just chanting solid principles in
every interview has kind of muted every
conversation around what good structure
looks like it Shadow is long and it's
Thoughtless and kind of full of Dogma
when you follow it blindly now as an
aside on another occasion I've done this
talk people said oh but don't you think
everything exists in a context and I
think there's probably some value to
that you know I think this book was very
important to a lot of people at a
certain point in time it certainly was
to me when I was early on in my career
but I think we can grow past and learn
from older works and move
on so I hear you scream heresy you can't
say that about clean
code um but you know I think instead of
this this notion of cleanliness and this
weird like
Craftsman metaphor that that series of
books really focuses on I've I've really
come to value intentionality in my code
above any sense of syntactic cleanliness
the more I think about this and you know
intentionality is a fairly abstract word
so let's talk about what I really mean
by that I mean literally every single
character on the screen matters
everyone you know if you think about
this as literature and as work I want
you to approach the work as if
everything is important and everything
has to have meaning every choice you
make is a choice you're
making the Whit space matters the rhythm
of the code matters the naming obviously
still matters form matters function
matters and code written with
thoughtfulness and intentionality that
are written for a reader matter more
than anything
else now thinking as your software where
as literature like this kind of lets you
value different ways of communicating in
code so we can communicate on the the
kind of the macro scale with
organizational patterns and application
architectures so let's take for example
MVC MBC is a an organizational pattern
it dictates how you split up your code
with all of its common implementations
and it basically tells you where to put
your files right now NBC is a weird
pattern that I have a LoveHate
relationship with because what MBC does
is it totally obos the intent of your
software MVC is a an organizational
pattern is most popularly used for web
applications in 20120 I look at an MVC
codebase I see a website I don't see
what the website is about I it it it's
hidden completely and you know it's a
good example of an organizational
pattern that is useful in one axis
because it helps people understand how
to maintain their software but actually
obscures a lot of the intent of what it
does so all I know is how the code base
is wired up when I look at the MVC
application now I actually find the
micro scale much more interesting than
the macro scale um where the way that
you form code from function to function
or module to module telegraphs intent
because of course we use form and flow
to increase cohesion in our code base
it's that same old axis of like cohesion
and coupling being these two things that
you get to play around with in
design Now by way of an example and
don't worry about the the details here
I'll I'll talk you through them of what
I mean when I say use form flow and
cohesion on the micro scale I want to
share two screenshots ironically from
that same code base that you saw before
now here's a relatively ugly mundane
function it does some HTTP stuff like
what it does isn't super interesting but
what it is is it's really difficult to
read and it's really difficult to read
because there is no form or function or
flow in this code
it forces your brain to comprehend
software literally one line at a time as
statements now we use paragraphs in
texts to guide the reader to group
related concepts by moving things
together before moving on to something
else code is the same what you're doing
when you start to reorganize code is
give the reader something to lead
through to read to pause to breathe with
lines mean something and if you use them
everywhere or nowhere you've removed the
intent you've taken away a whole form of
expression from your code now this is
like a really incredibly small scale
example that does great Injustice to the
effects of kind of code with good form
versus code with bad form but code with
good form is like poetry with rhythm it
reacts to a reader it directs a reader
it telegraphs how they're meant to
understand it it shows you what's
related significant things are grouped
the things on the left are more
important than the things on the right
its aesthetic sensibility reflects how
the form of and the flow of control of
the software is designed to be
interpreted and that's the interesting
thing and all I all I did was deleted
some lines like there was nothing big
that happened here but what I did is I I
spent time looking at it and thinking
about how I wanted someone to comprehend
it now the form and flow of your code is
something you use to communicate and
it's often lost in this kind of morass
of linters and auto formatters that
force a regular form without any concept
of context onto your code base form
intent its
design now the more I started thinking
about software through this lens of
literature through this lens of intent
the more it became really apparent to me
is that I was what I was really reacting
to was the inherent complexity of a lot
of modern software that your job as a
reader is to kind of load this this
context into your head so you can
comprehend the work and then you can
make a change and what I was really
doing was craving this clear
communication of a clear piece of
written pros of meaningful code and that
was really this horrible grander design
problem now I've been working on a
sentence recently and I think it's up on
the screen I can't see the screens from
here um and it's ridiculous to ever be
working on a sentence um what's your
life work I came up with some some
really cool short phrases um and and
it's this it's you know I believe that
the the real central point of design is
that the complexity of any application
you build should be at most as complex
as the problem space it inhibits and no
greater macro and micro designer tools
that we have to meet this goal and just
so many systems straight up fail this
thing and you know anytime you've opened
a thing and you you want to change a
line of text on a on a screen for in a
mediocre mundane web application and you
have to peel away layers of abstract
Factory Builder renderer view model God
knows what else I want to to
kill myself right like it's this is the
horrible bit right it's it's the worst
thing and systems just fail that sniff
test because all of the important work
is in a tiny Corner buried in everything
else right you're completely hiding the
work it buries systems it makes working
with them like swimming through treal
and it's often when people overdesign
they they apply too much design to a
small problem
space um and it's kind of like we forgot
how to build small programs because we
we basically drank the Kool-Aid of
decades and Decades of best practice
that told us we needed all of these
things in every system without stopping
to think that maybe we don't and maybe
actually we only have three problems and
we could just solve those right really
interesting like I love beautiful tiny
programs that do way more heavy lifting
than they have any means of doing
because they're so small and perfect and
they totally Encompass a problem
space now the interesting thing about
thinking about design like that and and
even using the word design is that
design can be thought of as contentious
you know much like software architecture
as like a building analogy that we put
on our domain design is a a visual skill
that we use to communicate information
you know designs exist to solve problems
to communicate intent again using Form
and Function that's why design is
different from
art but design is also temporal in
nature real regular design with many
designs only really making sense in the
context of their time and you know even
sometimes if great design can be
timeless anyway now if you look on the
outside of software great design is
really deeply contextual now there are
plenty of examples of products where
great period design applies um but
they're nonsense now so if you look at
these pictures like these two designs
are completely 100% obsolete the dead
technology we don't use any of this
stuff and a lot of our Legacy
applications contain design patterns now
that are as obsolete as as using these
things and haven't kind of changed with
the systems and the context changing
around them now there there's a really
observation a really interesting
observation here though that taking
those two particular iconic designs as
an example you might think these
products ex don't exist anymore but they
weren't actually the last of their their
lines they weren't they evolved and
changed over time and ironically kind of
converged and it's because design is
always iterative and it's always context
sensitive
like phones didn't cease to exist
Walkman didn't vanish what actually
happened is they were iterated out
towards touch phones and MP3 players and
mobile phones and dism and iPods and all
those things converged and you know they
actually converged because we just
discovered there was a beautiful
generalization in those two designs and
we weren't really trying to play music
or make phone calls at all we were just
trying to transmit audio right and
actually it's all the same problem and
that's great
design now I find it it really
interesting personally when I look at
like real world design to to see that
iterative step-by-step process because I
think it really neatly reflects the
iterative process of kind of tdd and
test driven design similarly right you
know I'm I'm sure you'll see like the
rising trend of people that have
criticized tdd because they don't
understand it and and whenever I see
people criticizing tdd the main thing
that always screams at me is they that
they always kind of say oh well I I had
to write the test first but I already
had the thing in my head and I didn't
get anything better and it seems like a
waste of time I was like yeah but the
the the tddd thing is like a red green
refactor iterative cyle and if you're
not doing the iteration you're not
really doing tdd you're just thinking of
a thing holding that in your head and
then trying to test your idea right like
the iteration is a fundamental part of
good design and you know one of the
things that I'm absolutely certain of is
people that if people think that that
cycle is redundant ceremony they've
never actually really felt it work for
them and they've never really it ated on
the
software
um so this Al also highlights one of the
other really kind of magical qualities
of design as a discipline itself which
is it's just as much about form as it is
about function there are like entire
categories of problem I personally
believe you can't feel until you see it
and one of the coolest things about tdd
is discipline is that when you see the
apis that you've kind of driven out you
can look at them and go like I don't
really like that it doesn't feel right I
don't think
I I feel like when someone reads that
they're going to be confused like that
kind of extra level of visual reasoning
that you get from looking at a thing and
interacting with it is super super
powerful and I think you know it's not
that I'm saying that without iteration
you can't build beautiful things but I
reckon you have to be a lot smarter than
I am because you're missing this entire
category of signal of being able to use
a malleable
thing now I appreciate there's kind of a
common Trope that programmers are not
visual people or don't feel like they
are but it's precise ly those visuals
that give you the ick when you open
software you might not think you're
visual but if you open a codebase and go
oh God who did this that is you
responding to visual signal in real time
straight
away so looking at this framing device
looking at software design as actual
design it's probably worth us thinking
about the context that modern software
exists in and how that might challenge
some of our more conventional approaches
to design it's kind of worth us
re-evaluating all of our organizational
PN
it to to kind of exist in this world
where we're not building software that
ships on DVDs for desktop computers
running MSS and Windows 95 because all
of the books about design patterns were
written when we were doing those things
and looking around the room I don't
think many of you are old enough to have
ever done
that now I'll tell you what all of the
10th Generation clean architecture
people really absolutely hate people
talking
about most of the things that
you describe as best practice are just
kind of overblown structural design
patterns normally sorry um and they kind
of look almost as silly as organizing by
architectural feature on sufficiently
small size systems like I see a lot of
system design these days where the bit
where where these ideas have been
fragmented into
microservices who am I kidding it's
always distributed monoliths always
every single time and and you know the
individual moving parts of those systems
have then been absolutely decimated by
best practice CU like cool you need to
solve four problems so you split them up
into four systems you make four
repositories and four sets of CI tools
and four sets of Automation and four
Target production environments Times by
three and oh my God I now have
problems right and this isn't me saying
just put all your code in one
place but what it what it means is when
you zoom out it looks like best practice
we got we got our we neatly separated
our concerns well high five so I want to
show you an example of another
application that I was trying to fix
that suffered from exactly this and
you're definitely not going to be able
to read the slide so don't worry just
look at the number of
things so this is a class diagram that I
generated from a system I was building
that was following a prescriptive clean
architecture pattern but all I see here
is complete dogmatic thoughtlessness so
the system which was being recompacted
back down into into a single logical
application was divided into a huge
number of modules all of which were
further subdivided by architectural
feature and each part of the application
had its own web app and a module and
some core libraries and a function and
eight different directories so they all
looked absolutely identical right and
the the total cognitive load of being
able to rationalize what any of this
stuff was doing was absolutely huge and
I think it was well-intentioned like
someone wasn't trying to make a mess but
all I see is an explosion of complexity
because all the invisible things really
really really damage the surface area of
the software and the the obvious big
comedy bit is it was all maintained by
one team of four people so I I don't get
it right and the irony is for all the
macro design that was going on the
project structure the the code like this
is a diff of me cleaning up one file
from the big load of mess to like four
lines right like this this is where we
ended up the state of the actual code
was horrendous it was all like copy past
a Guff it was horrible and all that
effort was focused on organizing files
into folders rather than focusing on the
code that really
mattered um so you know it was horrible
and I see things like this all the time
and I know everyone has systems like
this so how did we spot and fix this
well we did a f the first thing I
noticed actually was all of these
systems were being deployed to the same
application Service Group in Azure they
were being recombined at the end of all
of the work which was like the canary
and the coal mine of weird design so we
did a first round where we trimmed away
a lot of the complexity we collapsed all
the families of libraries together um
and rather than a web application
depending on a module and a core thing
they at least now were just directories
in the same application so we merged all
the all the things back together we then
went through all the organization by Fe
and we collocated all of the things that
were only used in one place to live
inside the code that was calling it and
then finally once we'd rationalized all
the C code base down and folded it in we
had 12 applications that we just
deployed in a single job and then we cut
and pasted all the stuff from all 12
into one and deployed it one time and
rerooted all the URLs deleted all the
code one single
application so after the work was
completed the we went from 64
independent moving Parts with 19 build
pipelines times three for each of our
environments into a single Deployable
application that we could fix by
systematically removing low-level code
rot using just standard old refactoring
tools and this is what I believe
adhering to these really really super
strict kind of clean architectur
organizational patterns actually lead
you to if you don't really really need
that complexity and again I'm not saying
those architectures are all bad I'm
saying make sure you have a problem that
requires them before littering your
system with
them um build smaller things where you
can now there are obviously certain
problem spaces where there are known
good structural design patterns and
that's cool not a problem you know the
most obvious example is kind of RPC
style systems with HTTP API calls now
they often map really neatly to kind of
command query pattern classes that
totally makes sense right they're good
rational organizational patterns but in
those systems where you have known good
patterns it's really important that the
form and your flow of the individual
implementation matters matters even more
I guess what I'm reaching for is it's
not just what you say but how you say it
and it matters because when your macro
level design all fits a well-known
pattern you kind of get this code
blindness when you're reading right and
you start to skim and you start to not
really read
and it's important to me that we use the
lowlevel details to actually communicate
what is different and where people need
to be paying
attention in
fact you know when I learned about MVC I
made this mistake everything was an MVC
app right um I I suffered from this
Affliction for for a lot of my career I
thought everything was a controller then
I learned about aspect oriented
programming and everything was an
Interceptor and I'm like cool I've got
my new shiny toy I'm going to do it to
every piece of software um I built a a
few di containers and I decided that
everything could be injected using Di
and some clever Factory logic definitely
did that um this is my Penance I think
um I then learned that controllers only
dealt with HTTP so then every piece of
logic became an application service
right and and I desperately in the
middle of my career tried tried to find
the good shape the answer that everyone
would be happy with me
for and I also when microservice design
first got popular blew up a 100 systems
into lots of moving parts right like
we've all done this we've all made these
mistakes and it's
cool but it takes some time from having
lived with these systems that you've
made these mistakes too to learn where
your designs fail and you know it takes
time to learn that uniformity is
actually the opposite of expressiveness
by trying to force everything into the
thing I liked the most at the time I sto
letting the programs breathe and look
like the things they really are so to me
it's really important that when
different parts of your system do things
that are different or break a pattern or
a mold they look look different because
then when I'm reading through the code
I'm like oh cool well the style has
changed here the the API has changed
here this is something I need to pay
attention to it's optimizing for the
reader using visuals to lead the eye it
encourages reading instead of
skimming we're going to talk about
complexity a little bit here now I kind
of have come to believe this this idea
of
intentionality is the is the inverse of
complexity
you know it's the stop doing things just
because it stop cargo culting design
decisions if you don't understand why
you're applying a pattern or a structure
so your code base you should really stop
doing it and and actually once you get
that mindset on every choice you're
making every Library you're adopting
every tool every framework is additional
complexity right and if you can't
justify that additional complexity of
picking up extra moving Parts you should
stop and think about it now
unfortunately because so much software
today is is really context sensitive
there are many times where blindly
applying design patterns Mak software
much more difficult to reason about and
what you're really doing is you're
increasing cognitive load right and our
job the job of design is to decrease
cognitive load so I want to go through
some techniques that we can use to
remove cognitive load in our
designs so when I talk about complexity
I often discover that lots of people
have different ideas of what complex
really means it's a kind of an
overloaded word
so I read this really great book called
a philosophy of software design by um
John
kout and I think it really gets to the
heart of like a great definition of what
complexity is in software I'd really as
an aside I'd recommend the book um but
it's second chapter is specifically
about complexity and design and it's
really really very good um and the
second chapter describes how software
complexity isn't like picking the wrong
framework generally
it's caused by tiny paper cuts and Tiny
bits of cruff that accumulate over time
rather than a catastrophic design
error it's from the collection of
dependencies and obscurities and
idiosyncrasies at work that's where
complexity comes from so user how
describes complexity as the thing that
leads to what he describes as change
amplification which leads to high
cognitive load unknown unknowns and then
an explosion of work and effort which
subsequently leads to the number number
of modifications required to make any
change high so that's that's kind of
your indicator right like if you're
making lots and lots of modifications to
to change a system it's a complex system
by Design so building on that definition
I think that intentional thoughtful
design is this kind of Salve for the
creeping rise of complexity surrounding
software so there's a distressing
realization When You Reach this line of
thinking which is that design patterns
are precisely popular because of exactly
that thing I was searching for in the
middle of my career they give people a
really easy nice green tick of a goal to
head towards like they give you
something you know is good like there's
an answer like a real definite answer to
what good looks like but once you've
seen enough code bases and enough
languages you kind of realize that most
of the arbitrary stylistic quirks of
those environments are just
that you know they're kind of fine you
don't really need to worry about them
people get lost in theep detail um you
know they're most mostly irrelevant so
what I've come to believe is that good
code is a couple of different things
right good code is code that's easy for
someone with minimal domain context to
read so code that your average developer
can understand is good that's easy code
that focuses on developer experience
debug ability and usability right code
that you cannot debug meaningfully is
Bag
code and code where the intent of the
software the the thing that you're doing
is lost in the visual noise of the
programming languages and tooling and
Frameworks is is bad code right so code
where there's more syntax than there is
operations that mean something in your
program bad
code so regardless of language or style
or intent all programmers really
interact with code Bas is the same way
you know what you do is you glance at it
to understand it and you go through what
it does and then you read it intently to
understand how it does it you kind of go
through this rapid cycle of like what is
this what am I doing how are you doing
that good code regardless of style makes
that process super
easy now at a meta level all code is
constructed from abstractions and
encapsulation like these are two very
very common
terms and this has always been true so
the programming languages run times and
Frameworks that we write code on top of
help go through an enormous amount of
kind of compilation translation
interpretation to let you write your
applications now the programming
languages themselves are common
abstractions over operating system apis
which are abstractions over Hardware
which are abstractions over assembled
languages and CPU instructions like this
trend continues upwards right and your
goal in your application and Library
space is to write increasingly narrow
abstractions that provide additional
value now
for the most part we get to be
blissfully unaware of this huge amount
of work that's that we're building
software on top of and that's because
the value that those abstractions bring
vastly outweigh the amount of mental
effort we have to go through to
comprehend them right so the the the
obvious example of this is you never
really worry about what file open does
but like file open is really really
complicated in every programming
language in every runtime on every
platform there are a lot of spinning
discs there's ssds there's memory
mapping there's file systems there's God
knows what right but as a developer
there's a really really beautiful neat
constrained abstractions of folders and
files that exists for you to interact
with right beautiful actual beautiful
design as you implement your own
software sadly it's not always the case
that the abstractions that you introduce
reduces cognitive load right like
getting to that beautiful point is
really difficult and it's often a very
subtle process to understand exactly why
one abstraction feels right and one
isn't so I'm going to borrow a little
bit more from that book um a bit more
terminology so when we think about this
example of file open I want you to um
consider the the idea of a module in
software now it doesn't matter what
programming language you work in we have
modules and modules expose functions and
they have some kind of API that we work
with um now the interface that a module
exposes represents the complexity that
that module imposes on on the software
that consumes it so the more stuff you
can do with a module the more complexity
you introduce your code base because the
problem space opens up so the smaller
and narrower the interfaces that you
expose by your modules the less
complexity you force upon the software
that consumes
them by that description you can think
of the best modules you can build as
deep now file open is a really really
beautifully deep module has a very very
narrow interface that trades in its own
types of files and directories you don't
know about hard disk blocks and the file
system and God knows what else and it's
very very deep because it completely
contains all of that detail in nice
abstraction so modules that offer deep
functionality through a narrow interface
are desirable and reduce the cognitive
load as you're building software the
inverse then is often true so an
interface with lots of functions or a
module that exposes lots of behavior and
lots of parameters and lots of types out
of the top forces that complexity up
onto the software that consumes it and
you know that makes your design worse
every time you do it your software
degrades in
quality so as much a factor of avoiding
the wrong abstractions is really finding
the right ones okay and it may seem like
really painfully obvious advice but
abstractions and generally like any
other module of code that you find
should contain their problem space
entirely that means that abstractions
that include things like pass through
methods and like I've seen so much code
where you're just brain deadly passing
things through I've written that code
myself what they're doing is every time
you do it you increase the complexity
right you're not gaining anything you're
only
losing um you know our software is
riddled with thoughtless abstraction and
poor encapsulation and every time a
design decision like that is made it
decreases the reason that the module
exists or the piece of software in its
entirety so anything that adds a large
amount of boiler plate code to an
application by this measure is bad
code now you get to a certain point
where you realize that all this talk
about kind of design and Dogma I guess
dissolves into kind of absolutism and
people searching for that one concrete
good answer because you know I can tell
you one truth here which is that any
design when stretched to its logical
extreme becomes
nonsense and it means that you know you
can look at systems that were beautiful
at one scale and make no sense at
another and that's totally fine you know
designing software with intent software
that survives really is an exercise on
compromise and tradeoffs and it's it's
really why anyone with experience in
designing software always says it
depends right it's the answer to every
design question is well don't know it
kind of depends what are the tradeoffs
and you know that that is the right
answer to be honest you know and a lot
of the poor trade-offs you see in the
software industry involve people
actively not understanding these sources
of complexity and often adopting
packages or Services they really don't
control and they don't understand which
then loads complexity on the software
that they're writing themselves you know
there's there's a lot to be said about
the lower risk and lower complexity of
maintaining 30 100 lines of code that
you control you might be able to get it
for free from a library but if you don't
you don't take on the the emotional
labor and the burden of the upgrade
cycle of that library and all the
additional complexity because
dependencies introduce these ex extra
surface areas into your code base and
all those extra features amplify
complexity over time and this is how we
end up with you know the the the classic
JavaScript leftpad problem where some
random dependency that was taken for a
fairly mundane thing got revoked and
broke a lot of
software now it's interesting because
it's really an uneasy bed fellow with
the conventional wisdom that like any
you know you shouldn't really build
software that you can buy you know every
line of code is cost everything you
build you maintain but I don't know like
the example I always use is I recently
wrote a 300 line static site generator
rather than using one because I spent an
hour looking at the State ofthe art and
I was just like God there's just so much
in here I could have this done in the
time it would take me to read the
documentation so I just wrote it myself
was fine I was just rendering like 20
Pages it didn't really matter my problem
space was small so I picked a small
answer all of your designs really should
be expressions of that kind of tradeoff
like if you need one feature from a
library maybe write it it's fine or copy
it it's fine that's what open source is
for right now in fact once you start
considering things as this like kind of
continual tradeoff what you realize is
instead of rules around system designs
you end up with tests and I don't mean
coded tests or unit tests I mean you end
up with design tests that you evaluate
your your choices on I want you I want
to take you through a few tests that I
use to to select what I think a good
design looks like now this is my my
favor favorite test always is can I do
this with less moving
parts now the kind of the yeah a
solution with less moving parts and less
systems and less cognitive load is
easier to rationalize support and
maintain the one with
more now any additional moving parts and
this is where a lot of the push back
from people that have always built Big
systems comes against microservice
architectures there's just so much stuff
and every extra moving part is something
that could break and often there's a
good reason to choose a moving part but
it shouldn't just be the default
answer um there are many places in our
ecosystem where this kind of ballooning
complexity makes working with systems
just harder than they should be so we
should never extract parts of our
applications to elsewhere just because
just because is the dumbest reason never
use it right so break up individual
systems and components when they need to
either ship scale deploy or be
maintained
distinctly like you only really break
down systems when the usage pattern
change that's the important
rule is this operable in a production
environment again lots and lots of cool
things that people promote to me are
just not operable software they can't be
maintained they can't be upgraded they
can't be patched they can't be observed
if you have a dependency that seems cool
but isn't operable it's just a burden
and it will take your sight down at some
point you can't pick it you can't use it
so software where the design is
difficult to configure or deploy bad
software is it easy to
change now the best software is software
that's easy to change because the only
thing I can guarantee about your
software is you will have to change it
and one of the things I often have to
talk about at work when dealing with can
of our stakeholders is that you know
they want us to get things 100% right
where they can never have any errors and
I I end up having these long
conversations around the fact that I can
never guarantee that any of our software
will ever work I can only promise that
it will fail at some point so that's
actually the scenario we need to design
for um so again avoid overdesign and
focus on Simplicity
first so I guess as we come to the end
of this what I'm really advocating for
here when I plead for intentionality is
for you to write your software with care
and with purpose you know I want you to
think about the design of your software
I want you to think about the reader I
want you to think about your friends I
want you to think about your peers I
want you to think about what form and
flow means to the software and I want
you to use all of these forms of
expression that are available to you in
your codebase to communicate meaning and
intent you know different problem spaces
and different solutions require
different aesthetic viewpoints and we
should really Embrace that you know you
know lest we Dam ourselves to the two
default designs which is everything is a
jumble of components and HTTP calls or
everything is an MVC app and I don't
want to work that way so it doesn't have
to be that way right and and we can be
better because when you look at software
that's someone has built with care it
really shows like it shows when you you
use a library in something it's easy to
work with where the documentation makes
sense like I see you all of you
programmers I see you when I see the
effort that you put into the work and
like I super deeply feel like this is
our work and I I I think back to myself
as an art student and like you know that
would have been my work this is the
work so I was on a podcast a couple of
years ago and and someone asked that
really really obvious predictable
question that always comes up oh what
would you tell to yourself 20 years ago
when you were starting your career and I
always used to hate that question
because I never had an answer for it but
now I know now I know the answer is take
more time take more time all of the most
beautiful things that I ever built all
the things that people love the most
were when I finished and I sat and I
just read the work and I thought what
was I doing why did I do that that makes
no sense sense because if I'm sitting
there reading it and seeing that
everybody else is too right so all of
the things that I've made that were ever
beautiful because I sat there and I read
critically like a reader and fixed the
things before anyone ever saw it and I
think that's super important just take
time it's beautiful so I want to leave
you with a couple of reading
recommendations as as we finish up here
partially because I don't really think
there are many books on this topic right
design is something that's hard to talk
about all three of these books are
really good so there's a philosophy of
software design which is John osterhout
which I've been quoting from in this
deck does your code as a crime scene by
Adam torill he's written another book
that follows that up that also is crime
sceney which is about understanding how
your code has changed over time through
kind of G forensics which is super
interesting and code that fits in your
head by Mark Seaman talks in detail
about kind of different ways that you
can refactor through your code bases to
make them more
legible um they're obviously far more
exhausted than any 1hour conference talk
could be on on this topic but they're
all brilliant I really do recommend you
read them and also support the authors
in our community it's nice isn't
it so ever seen a talk before that could
be summarized as it it
depends this talk um I like talking
about things like design and language in
literature because when you talk about
words they mean things and we grow our
language and then we can talk about them
some more um I love talking about this
stuff please please hit me up I hope
this was interesting and gave you a bit
of a different perspective on how to
think about design than the regular just
do these four things and you'll be great
and everything will be rainbows and
kittens and I don't know other nice
things so Care thank you
[Applause]
please